il est des habitudes qui méritent d'être
cultivées
et je suis heureux d'être parmi vous
pour ouvrir cette deuxième rencontre au
Sénat du grand continent
après la place de la France et de
l'Europe face au rivalité entre la Chine
et les États-Unis et avouer que
l'actualité nous rappelle que ça n'était
pas un thème j'allais dire hors sol or
géopolitique et hors temps
c'est la démocratie en Europe et en
France que nous nous apprêtons à
ausculter dans un contexte de crise qui
interroge le rôle de chaque acheteur
institutionnel et naturellement les
parlements je tiens à rappeler le sens
de nos rencontres qui est de multiplier
les passerelles entre le monde
académique et l'univers parlementaire
dans le chaos des certitudes tranchantes
de l'immédiatet triomphante nous avons
fait ensemble avec vous en continuant
le choix d'un autre tempo la réflexion
la mise à distance le rejet de
l'impulsivité
qui tient lieu trop souvent de force de
conviction
évoqué dans la fable de La Fontaine
dans le lièvre et la tortue dont je
rappelle toujours qu'elle a été écrit un
moment où le Sénat n'existait point
et où c'était le souvenir du Sénat
romain qui incarnait la sagesse et la
paix c'est donc loin ce train de
sénateur d'être synonyme d'hésitation
il veut octroyer la décision des racines
solides prendre le temps c'est écouter
et entendre en épousant le pas de la
sagesse
mesdames et messieurs
la démocratie
européenne est confrontée à une crise
aux multiples facettes crise économique
et sociale inflation
crise de l'identité
monter des radicalité tendance il
libérale
guerre aux portes et j'allais dire en
Europe
la crise ne se limite d'ailleurs pas aux
frontières de l'Union européenne comme
on a témoigné aux yeux du monde l'assaut
du Capitole c'était le 6 janvier 2021 à
Washington
cette crise ne me paraît pas cependant
contester les fondements du modèle
démocratique il n'est pas de société
européenne qui envisage de rompre avec
l'héritage démocratique au profit de
régime autoritaire personne personne
dans nos pays ne peut considérer
sérieusement que les régimes
autoritaires soient mieux armés pour
affronter les grands défis malgré des
tentations qui ont existé mais vite
dissipées au premier temps de l'épidémie
de covid
à contrario exige dans nos sociétés une
vive dénonciation d'un déficit de
démocratie et un appétit de plus en plus
grand pour la démocratie participative
on peut d'ailleurs se demander si la
crise n'est pas consubstantielle à la
démocratie la démocratie porte en elle
un état de tension entre majorité et
minorité
la promesse d'expression de la volonté
de chacun et en fait
aussitôt par sa dissolution dans
le destin collectif
la démocratie en plus me paraît sans
cesse perfectible
à la question les démocraties
européennes sont-elles menacées dans
leur existence face à la crise présente
point d'interrogation je réponds ce
n'est pas ma conviction
parlons de la démocratie en France et de
la crise dans notre pays
les comparaisons européennes sont
souvent instrumentalisées pour lisser
des effets de la crise dans tel ou tel
pays
et montrer que la situation est
finalement moins grave ou en tout
comparable c'est je pense aussi une
erreur de perspective
la France perte sert tous les traits des
crises européennes mais ils ne sont plus
accusés en son sein que dans les pays de
son voisinage
pays de voisinage qui ont su canaliser
les expressions politiques les plus
radicales regardez récemment en Espagne
ou conforter une culture du pacte social
premier compromis le compromis des
polders dont on parle peu aux Pays-Bas
mais qui parle à un ancien ministre du
Travail qui en charge la réforme de
l'article premier du Code du travail
mais aussi
secrétaire général honoraire en
Allemagne
vous qui connaissez bien la situation
politique en Allemagne où trouver une
formule
identitaire
faisons le lien entre des traditions et
une modernité
et modernité dans les sens et d'être
ouverte sur le monde
faut-il réfléchir l'exemple du
Royaume-Uni sur ce sujet
la France est un précipité singulier un
alliage inédit entre interrogation
identité et commotion sociale
la crise française actuelle n'est pas
non plus la simple résultante de choix
non réglés ou de décision trop longtemps
reportée
toute crise puise indéniablement ses
racines dans le passé mais elle ne se
produit qu'à un moment donné et pas un
autre
fermez les yeux sur ce moment
l'écarter d'un revers de main pour
renvoyer les responsabilités à ces
prédécesseurs reviendrait à une forme
d'aveuglement c'est l'expression de
pierre aux invalons et d'échecs dans
l'exercice du pouvoir
il serait vain enfin de tenter d'édifier
des barrières étanches entre crise
sociale et crise politique toute
contestation sociale ne débouche pas
nécessairement sur le champ politique
mais rare sont les contestations
politiques qui ne soient pas nourries de
contestation sociale la contestation
sociale n'est pas le degré mineur de la
contestation politique auquel on
voudrait la circonscrire elle en devient
l'une des expressions c'est le
glissement entre les deux phénomènes qui
permet au mieux de saisir la portée de
la crise française
bien au-delà de la question
naturellement cruciale
des retraites alors
crise politique
crise des institutions crise
démocratique crise de régime je suis
avec des points d'interrogation je sais
que parmi nos intervenants de ce soir il
existe des analyses différentes de la
mienne mais je crois que c'est l'intérêt
de ce type de débat
crise de gouvernance sans aucun doute
pour moi et crise de l'autorité crise
d'une autorité qui se voulait
jupitérienne et verticale et à chercher
à contourner depuis des années le
Parlement
les territoires les corps intermédiaires
crises de la capacité à convaincre par
une parole de vérité et non des effets
d'annonce ou d'éléments de langage
répété jusqu'à qu'ils attiennent la
vacuité crise de résultats certainement
parce que trop souvent les mesures
annoncées l'ont été encore et encore
avec des effets réduits
crise entre la France oubliée et la
France de toutes les opportunités donc
crise de cohésion nationale lorsque les
paroles brutales divisent lorsque
l'intégration est abandonnée aux
communautarisme
crise dans l'exercice du pouvoir
assurément
la responsabilité politique n'est-elle
pas de rechercher le moyen de conjuguer
la légalité et la légitimité d'éviter
quand ils Gones de défi Créon
et d'accorder et là je convoque
Montesquieu la lettre et l'esprit des
lois
force et de reconnaître que ce ressort
démocratique c'est grippé
mais avant tout c'est la crise d'un
pouvoir du pouvoir en place qui doit
trouver une issue politique au delà d'un
chapelet une mesure technique dont on
peine à distinguer le fil conducteur
quelle perspective de sortie de crise
a-t-elle été définie oui qu'elle
perspective a été définie cette question
majeure demeure encore aujourd'hui sans
réponse
je ne fais pas partie vous l'avez
compris de ce qui invoquent une crise
systémique je crois en la responsabilité
politique
mesdames et messieurs
le Parlement par le contrôle de l'action
gouvernementale par le vote de la loi
permet d'ajuster la lettre à l'esprit la
légalité à la légitimité démocratique il
est au cœur du contrat social au cours
de ces dernières semaines je le dis dans
la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales le Sénat fait la
démonstration qu'il était en mesure
d'accueillir un débat riches parfois vif
parfois même très vif de basculant
jamais dans la victime en cohérence avec
ses convictions est capable de se
prononcer sur le fond dans une totale
indépendance du pouvoir en place des
injonctions politiques ou des émotions
du moment
me paraît avoir dans sa diversité
assumée sa mission qui est aussi une
mission d'être un balancier
stabilisateur des instituts
est une chance parce qu'il n'aligne pas
de façon systématique les majorités
législatives parce que le Sénat est ma
nation des collectivités territoriales
et autant attachée aux libertés locales
aux libertés individuelles et collective
il est l'un des carents en période de
crise il se méfie toujours des lois de
pulsion quand on annonce le mercredi un
projet de loi pour des événements
s'étant situé le dimanche nous venons de
le vivre aujourd'hui même c'est la
réalité politique de l'instant
oui
lorsque les temps sont troublés la
tentation en France
est forte lancer un chantier
institutionnel
qui est souvent un écran dissimulant une
forme de faiblesse politique
ne touchons à la constitution que d'une
main tremblante prenons garde aux
ajustements qualifiés techniques qui
bouleversent en fait des équilibres
institutionnels subtiles
je n'ignore pas que ce séjour vrai
besoin de respiration démocratique et je
le mets au pluriel elles ne peuvent être
de pure forme le référendum est l'un des
instruments de cette respiration mais
faisons attention à ce que la décision
du peuple soit respectée ce qui n'a pas
toujours été le cas je pense au
référendum en France sur la Constitution
européenne de 2005
et localement au référendum sur
Notre-Dame-des-Landes deux exemples qui
conduisent parfois douter et de croyez
pas nous nous faisons encore reprocher
puisque j'ai appartenu je le dire ce
gouvernement les conséquences que nous
n'avons pas tirées du référendum de 2005
lui sur nous bouleversé un peu la donne
en Europe c'est quand même une réalité
dont je peux faire état la seconde
instrument de cette respiration
démocratique peut-être le découplage des
élections présidentielles législatives
pour retisser le lien distendu avec les
citoyens redonner confiance et enrayer
une abstention toujours plus élevée tout
cela mérite d'être examiné d'ailleurs le
président de la commission des lois et
là et nous sommes en train de l'examiner
dans le cadre du groupe de travail
institutionnel
je terminerai par un mot sur la relation
des parlements nationaux avec le Conseil
la Commission et le Parlement européen
européen et non pluriel parce que ce
sont ces trois
institutions que je souhaite interroger
les citoyens européens aspirent plus de
démocratie et légitimité dans une
décision européenne qui paraît encore à
beaucoup éloignée de leur préoccupation
et parfois technocratique l'Union
européenne qui protège est aussi celle
qui impose certaines normes dont ils
contestent le bien-fondé or la
compétence des parlements nationaux
malgré le traité de Lisbonne reste
difficile à mettre en oeuvre contrainte
par Derek de procédure corseté
restreinte dans ses capacités d'orienter
des choix majeurs quelques exemples
dans l'approbation des traités de
libre-échange
quel rôle reste-t-il au Parlement
nationaux
on l'a vu avec le CETA
et Parlement nationaux avait encore le
pouvoir dossier du MERCOSUR ou de
l'accord avec la Nouvelle-Zélande c'est
typiquement à des saisissements des
parlements nationaux comment effectuer
un contrôle de subsidiarité efficace
lorsque la Commission européenne en
maîtrise les règles l'appréciation sur
le fond et le calendrier quand on
reparle de la doctrine de la séparation
là on se pose des questions
la crise de la démocratie européenne
revêt aussi le visage d'un défaut
d'associations des parlements nationaux
je le dis devant le président de la
commission pour l'Union européenne avec
ses côtés j'aurais vraiment saluer
Jean-Baptiste lent parce que si on est
là on lui doit beaucoup cher
Jean-Baptiste blanc et je voulais
vraiment vous remercier il est en train
de faire un travail absolument
passionnant mais assez rébarbatif sur un
objet très particulier qui s'appelle le
0 artificialisation nette autre idée de
venue ici le chantre et le connaisseur
oui
je reviens au défaut de l'Association
des parlements nationaux il s'agit d'un
chantier immense que la conférence sur
l'avenir de l'Europe nake fleurie
en dehors de ces parlementaires
vraiment je voulais
remarquer au retour de la conférence de
Prague vous représentiez le Sénat
que la voie de la France au moment de la
présidente française ne s'est guère fait
entendre pour promouvoir le rôle des
parlements nationaux
mesdames et messieurs j'aurais pu dans
le fond me contenter de citer de
Churchill dans son discours la Chambre
des communes le 11 novembre 1947
celui qui comporte son célèbre aphorisme
la démocratie et la pire forme de
gouvernement à l'exception de tous les
autres mais je suis revenu à lire ce
discours
en fait il est dans l'opposition il est
dans l'opposition à Clément atelier
et qu'est-ce qu'il dit quand le
gouvernement veut amenuiser le pouvoir
de veto de la chambre haute il déclare
il déclare
la démocratie ne signifie pas nous avons
une majorité je le cite peu importe
comment et nous avons un bail pour 5 ans
nous avons une majorité peu importe
fin de citation à méditer
et Churchill de poursuivre
Churchill de poursuivre le gouvernement
du peuple par le peuple pour le peuple
voilà la définition souveraine de la
démocratie est-ce que tout n'est pas dit
et je voudrais remercier Jean-François
Papin parce que
si aujourd'hui nous abordons ce thème
c'est à lui que nous le devons comme
président de la commission pour l'Union
européenne et je voulais vous dire que
puisqu'on va parler d'Europe qu'ici la
question européenne n'est pas une
question subsidiaire elle est une
question transversale pour chacune de
nos commissions et l'organisation que
nous avons dans une commission pour
l'Union européenne et quelque chose de
particulièrement intéressant avec
notamment des dispositifs d'alerte sur
les surtranspositions que nous avons mis
en place ici que tous les parlements
nationaux n'ont pas encore mis en place
mais qui nous apparaissent extrêmement
important je vous souhaite une
excellente moment de partage et
d'échange et je donne immédiatement la
parole
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président cher Gérard
Larcher Mesdames et Messieurs mes
collègues de
présidente commission monsieur le
Premier testeur madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Ambassadeurs
Madame et Monsieur le Professeur émérite
Monsieur le Secrétaire général honoraire
mes chers collègues sénateurs mes chers
collègues
je suis particulièrement heureux ce soir
dans le sillage du président Larcher
d'ouvrir la deuxième édition des
Rencontres du grand continent au Sénat
je saisis cette occasion pour souligner
combien le partenariat scellé entre
notre assemblée et votre revue me semble
opportun quand ma qualité de président
de la commission des affaires
européennes j'estime en effet que
l'ambition du Sénat d'être le creuset
d'un débat public représentatif
prospectif et stratégique prend toute sa
valeur quand elle se place d'une part à
la bonne échelle c'est-à-dire celle de
notre continent et d'autre part à la
bonne distance avec L'écume des jours
dirais-je c'est à dire quand elle
parvient à transcender
la caducité du tweet
c'est ce même positionnement qui je le
comprends distingue votre revue qui a su
en seulement 4 ans s'imposer comme une
référence de premier plan
en misant d'emblée sur la traduction en
plusieurs langues européennes le grand
continent atteste sa conscience aiguë
que tous les peuples européens doivent
naturellement prendre part au débat
public sur les enjeux du monde contre
contemporain en prenant du champ avec
l'actualité tout en suivant de près
votre revue elle s'autorise à voir plus
loin et plus haut ou plus au fond ce qui
revient au même et en temps structuré
une réflexion informée grâce au
croisement de divers disciplines c'est
ainsi qu'elle peut légitimement
ambitionner de nourrir utilement le
débat public et donc naturellement celui
qui nous anime ici au sein
c'est à ce même effort de prise de
distance que nous sommes invités ce soir
pour appréhender ce qu'il advient de la
démocratie dans les crises que traverse
notre continent c'est-à-dire dans ces
moments rares qui appellent une réponse
urgente pouvant justifier des procédures
dérogatoires et le contournement
exceptionnel des parlements je prendrai
un point de vue un peu latéral par
rapport à l'intitulé de cette rencontre
centrée sur le rôle des parlements face
aux crises qui affectent les démocraties
européennes et en fait je voudrais faire
une remarque fondamentale qui va en
entraîner des autres la question c'est
de quoi est-ce qu'on parle quand on
parle de démocratie
et Sylvie si je parle d'expérience
démocratique ou de démocratique comme
expérience
c'est parce que la démocratie ne se
réduit pas un système juridico-politique
qu'elle n'est pas seulement un mode de
gouvernement ou un régime au sens étroit
du terme c'est à dire à certains modes
de répartition d'organisation
d'exercices du pouvoir bien sûr un
certain nombre d'éléments de structure
institutionnelles sont fondamentaux
l'existence d'un état de droit la
séparation ou plutôt l'équilibre des
pouvoirs plus conformes l'idée et à
l'inspiration dans Montesquieu la
présence des contres pouvoirs tout ceci
est absolument essentiel mais la
démocratie c'est aussi comme le disait
Tocqueville dans la démocratie en
Amérique une forme de société
et une forme de société cela implique
des dispositions subjectives propres à
l'homo-démocraticus c'est à dire une
manière d'être et de vivre ou de ne pas
vivre ensemble un style d'existence des
mœurs des assises mentales et affectives
c'est en ce sens que la démocratie est
une expérience qui englobe à la fois les
pratiques de pouvoir et des positions
subjectives en particulier la démocratie
c'est ce régime paradoxal où la
contradiction publique des actions du
pouvoir est considérée comme légitime
on doit être attentif aux institutions
mais à la condition de considérer que la
démocratie c'est d'abord un mode
d'existence qui ne se réduit pas à la
sanction électorale il y a des formes
strictement procédurales la démocratie
représentative ne signifie pas que les
citoyens doivent rester silencieux après
avoir voté et en attendant la prochaine
élection à côté des élections ils
gardent la possibilité de s'exprimer de
contester de délibérer et surtout d'être
entendu
car la représentation électorale ce
n'est pas un simple transfert qui remet
ce n'est pas une délégation pure récente
qui remet la volonté des citoyens entre
les mains de leurs élus une fois que les
citoyens ont voté il ne cessent pas pour
autant d'exercer leur capacités
politiques et c'est précisément la
caractéristique des régimes qu'on
appelle il libéraux que de mettre la
puissance d'agir des citoyens à la
disposition des chefs qu'ils ont
désignés et dans une démocratie digne de
ce nom la liberté de l'opinion publique
implique le droit des gouvernés à
exprimer à tout moment leurs opinions
politiques et leur protestations
Benjamin Constant qu'on ne saurait
soupçonné d'être tenté par le chaos
politique et le désordre social
insistait sur la nécessité que je cite
d'une surveillance active et constante
exercée par le peuple sur ses
représentants en dehors du suffrage de
la liberté chez les modernes mais tout
n'est pas qu'à faire de procédures ou
tout n'est pas seulement à faire de
procédures la démocratie au sens plein
du terme implique que les citoyens se
représentent et s'éprouvent de manière
réflexive comme des acteurs politiques
afin de disposer véritablement d'une
force alternative ce qui fait que la
démocratie est toujours dans une
position instable menacée de deux façons
soit que le lieu soit que les dirigeants
prétendent incarner dans leur personne
le pouvoir du peuple soit que le lieu du
pouvoir
apparaissent aux citoyens comme un lieu
vide accaparé par les très particulier
et c'est là que nous devons faire
intervenir un certain nombre d'éléments
relatifs à la crise et qui déborde de
beaucoup l'idée de gouvernement et qui
nous permettent de comprendre
aujourd'hui ce qui se joue quand on
évoque la crise des démocraties
contemporaine donc très rapidement sur
la question de la crise donc il serait
hors de propos de développer les tenants
et les adoucisseurs les aboutissants je
ne m'étendrai pas sur un certain nombre
de constats récurrents bien connu la
montée de la défiance des citoyens à
l'égard les institutions des
représentants le déficit général de
légitimité qui se traduit notamment par
la volonté de l'abstention la
désaffection à l'égard des mots
traditionnelle etc etc donc on a un
certain nombre de signes extrêmement
divers qui témoignent non seulement de
l'essoufflement mais d'une crise très
profonde or cette crise et c'est le
propre de la notion de crise ne relève
pas simplement d'un constat objectif
elle engage la subjectivité elle engage
les positions subjectives des individus
leur perception ce qu'ils éprouvent si
je l'aurais fait au sondage déjà très
ancien enfin ancien publié par Le Monde
en novembre 2016 et par le sévi pof plus
récemment en mars 2020 après l'enquête
sur le à propos du baromètre de la
confiance politique non seulement une
majorité de français estime que la
démocratie fonctionne de moins en moins
bien l'appréciation n'est certes pas
nouvelle et vous avez rappelé la phrase
de Churchill qui est une matrice de la
réflexion sur la démocratie sauf que en
général on ne cite pas la dernière
partie de la phrase qui est fiancé il
dit la démocratie et le moins mauvais de
tous les régimes à l'exception de tous
ceux qui ont été expérimentés dans
l'histoire bon expérimenter le mot n'est
peut-être pas neutre quand on envisage
la démocratie comme comme expérience et
il y a quelque chose d'un petit peu
comment dire préoccupant dans les
résultats de ces derniers sondages qui
est que loin de considérer que la
démocratie est irremplaçable un certain
nombre une grande majorité de
l'individus envisage de manière positive
les bénéfices possibles d'un
gouvernement technocratique qui serait
guidés par des experts ça irait beaucoup
plus vite et on s'éviterait c'est comme
on va dire c'est pérégrinations
absolument comme on va dire sans fin et
ou même d'un système autor ou les
contre-pouvoirs de freineraient plus
l'action de l'exécutif donc ces
appréciations subjectives marquent quand
même une inflexion relativement récente
parce qu'elles émoignent de la fin d'un
consensus où tous ou presque tous se
proclamaient démocrates en dépit de
leurs insatisfactions de leur déception
et de leur critique mais c'est le
troisième et dernier point que je
voudrais souligner on assiste aussi à
des mouvements inverse à des tentatives
de
réappropriation de la capacité citoyenne
qui témoigne d'une prise de conscience
la prise du conscience du fait que la
démocratie n'est pas une forme politique
comme une autre
si nous la préférons si nous la
privilégions c'est précisément qu'elle
répond à une exigence fondamentale que
les individus puissent être à la fois
sujet capable d'obéissance civique et
citoyen agissant libre et égaux comme le
disait Rousseau être à la fois sujet et
citoyens ou encore obéir à la loi que
l'on sait soi-même prescrite en ce sens
la démocratie est comme le disait aussi
Spinoza le régime qui permet
d'actualiser la puissance d'agir des
hommes qui permet d'actualiser leur
puissance collective elle actualise
l'idée que le pouvoir ne réside pas
seulement dans un rapport vertical entre
ceux qui commandent et ceux qui
obéissent mais qu'il est aussi comme le
disait Anna Arendt à nagir ensemble qui
n'appartient à personne personne des
détenteurs de la souveraineté du peuple
ce qui
occupe le lieu du pouvoir ils sont
locataires et non propriétaires doivent
être certes respectées en tant que tel
mais ils ne peuvent prétendre incarner à
eux seuls la légitimité démocratique et
c'est à la lumière de ces réflexions via
la question des parlements que doit être
réenvisager la question de la
représentation puisque c'est ça qui est
au cœur de notre discussion de ce soir
elle ne consiste pas simplement
à être représenté ce n'est pas
simplement être représenté à la voix
passive
être représenté par ses représentants
mais elle met en jeu le fait de se
représenter soi-même de nous représenter
nous-mêmes de manière réflexive comme
citoyen agissant et de nous reconnaître
comme tel c'est cette conscience
réflexive qui évidemment entraîne
l'attention portée au rôle des
parlements des corps intermédiaires et
les associations mais aussi de tous les
acteurs de la société civile et
syndicale et ces deux cette conception
de la représentation que procède les
résistances à la verticalisation du
pouvoir c'est pourquoi à côté du rythme
ou des scansions électorales la
dynamique démocratique implique à la
fois des modalités de contestation
d'expression des désaccords et des
modalités de participation qui
accompagnent nécessairement la
revolarisation du rôle des parlements
donc je pense que à la fois nous
percevons aujourd'hui dans la crise qui
nous touche un certain nombre de choses
très graves qui portent atteintes elle a
dynamique démocratique et sa créativité
mais à contrario je dirais que le fait
d'envisager la démocratie non pas
simplement comme un ensemble procédural
les communes dynamique comme une
invention comme disait Claude Lefort
nous conduit au-delà des procédures
institutionnelles déjà existantes et
nous ne pouvons nous éprouver nous-mêmes
comme citoyen agissant que si nous
retrouvons le sens de l'invention
démocratique c'est dans cette
perspective pour moi que s'inscrit la
question de la représentation et du rôle
des parlements c'est à dire imaginer
des procédures qui organiseraient les
pratiques démocratiques sur le plan
institutionnel et qui organise qui
organiseraient des actions citoyennes
répondant à cette dynamique voilà je
vous remercie
merci beaucoup Myriam Thierry Chopin je
vous donne la parole à vous remercier
encore une fois pour votre amitié et
d'avoir répondu présent en même temps si
court vous avez proposé de parler à une
dizaine de minutes donc je salue votre
courage sur les évolutions de
transformation des institutions
démocratiques européennes au cours des
15 dernières années et des crises de
l'Union européenne donc la parole est à
vous pour 10 minutes merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup Gilles bonsoir à toutes
et à tous merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président pour votre accueil au sein de
de la Haute Assemblée je vais essayer de
faire un pas de côté finalement par
rapport à ce que vient de dire Myriam
revaudalon et notamment peut-être en
focalisant mon propos sur la dimension
peut-être de la démocratie comme forme
comme forme politique ou
institutionnelle et par ailleurs
peut-être un deuxième pas de côté en
abordant cette question à l'échelle
européenne
le sujet portait la démocratie
européenne face aux crises et je
parlerai pour ma part de la démocratie
de l'Union européenne plus plus
spécifiquement de manière à recentrer la
focale je voudrais faire essentiellement
deux séries de remarques dans les 10
minutes que tu as bien voulu me donner
d'abord peut-être effectivement tirer
quelques leçons des 15 années de crise
qui viennent de s'écouler pour la
gouvernance de l'Union européenne je
crois qu'il y a des leçons qu'on peut en
tirer qui sont intéressantes pour pour
analyser l'équilibre ou plutôt les
déséquilibres entre le pouvoir exécutif
européen et la dimension parlementaire
de l'Union européenne et puis je ferai
une seconde série de remarques peut-être
davantage centrée sur sur la France en
tout cas du point de vue de son
organisation institutionnelle en matière
de politique européenne avec quelques
pistes peut-être d'ailleurs de
propositions susceptibles de vous
intéresser en matière de renforcement de
la responsabilité de l'exécutif
vis-à-vis du Parlement dans dans ce
domaine sur le premier point d'abord
donc quelques leçons sur les 15 ans de
crise qui viennent de s'écouler vous
l'avez monsieur le Président rappelé
depuis 2008
l'Union européenne a été confrontée à un
certain nombre de crises qui se sont qui
se sont enchaînés après lesquels on a on
a couru en réalité et ces crises en fait
d'ailleurs qu'on peut qu'on pourrait
qualifier de choc de souveraineté elle
touche toutes à des enjeux régaliens
d'une manière ou d'une autre toutes ces
crises finalement ont d'abord eu
peut-être des vertus positives au sens
où elles ont provoqué une mobilisation
politique hors norme au plus haut niveau
des États au niveau chef d'État et
gouvernement vous avez mentionné la
montée en puissance du Conseil européen
non pas dans le triangle institutionnel
communautaire mais dans le quadrilatère
finalement que représente la gouvernance
de l'Union européenne aujourd'hui
et effectivement cette montée en
puissance des chefs d'État de
gouvernement sans doute s'explique par
deux raisons fondamentales d'abord la
légitimité politique de ces chefs d'État
et de gouvernement face à de tels enjeux
et par ailleurs le fait que les États
disposent de moyens budgétaires
évidemment qui ne sont pas ceux de
l'Union européenne en tant que tel en
même temps si je puis dire
cette montée en puissance du Conseil
européen a eu des conséquences
ambivalentes voire négatives me
semble-t-il au moins pour ce qui
concerne les crises entre 2008 et 2015
dans la mesure où ce qu'on a pu
percevoir c'est un certain nombre
d'effets négatifs de cette gouvernance
de crise par l'échelle d'état de
gouvernement lenteur de la négociation
diplomatique d'abord
incertitude lié à la désynchronisation
des moments politiques nationaux en
Europe qui est entraîne en fait une
difficulté d'abord à se mettre d'accord
mais même le cas échéant quand on
parvient à se mettre d'accord au niveau
des chefs d'État de gouvernement la
possibilité que les décisions prises
puissent être remises en cause du fait
d'un changement de gouvernement ou un
changement de majorité dentelle ou tel
État membre
sans doute les crises plus récentes je
pense à la crise du covid je pense
également à la guerre en Ukraine
permettent de dire qu'on a peut-être
tiré commencé à tirer des leçons des
effets négatifs de cette gouvernance de
crise par
le Conseil européen en tout cas on a
pris moins de temps à prendre les
décisions qui qui s'imposaient mais à
nouveau on voit bien que le véritable
souverain c'est la nécessité
ça ne relève pas en réalité d'un choix
de type démocratique au sens où ce choix
cette décision aurait fait l'objet au
préalable d'un débat informé au sein
d'enceintes parlementaires comme on est
en droit de l'attente de l'attendre
pardon quand on est en démocratie sans
parler effectivement de ce que vous avez
mentionné également l'usage d'un certain
nombre de dispositions juridiques des
traités je pense à l'article 122 du
traité de l'Union européenne mais dont
parlera sans doute Klaus vélo dans un
instant qui a tendance à mettre entre
parenthèses le rôle du Parlement
européen dans cette gestion de crise
même si l'urgence en fait à nouveau nous
contraint à prendre les décisions en
question donc politique de l'urgence
politique de l'événement si on veut
reprendre une expression des désormais
célèbres
qui pose un certain nombre de problèmes
et en réalité qui me semble poser deux
problèmes fondamentaux le premier en
termes d'efficacité le second en termes
de légitimité le mot est souvent revenu
dans les présentations et les discours
qui qui viennent d'être prononcés sur le
registre de l'efficacité d'abord ce qui
est très frappant c'est que finalement
certains observateurs certains acteurs
se satisfont en réalité de du fait que
le Conseil européen cette rayon des
chefs d'État de gouvernement soit devenu
serait devenu j'utilise le conditionnel
le véritable pouvoir exécutif de l'Union
européenne sous une très particulière
comme un pouvoir exécutif collectif
c'est sans doute vrai empiriquement mais
par contre est-ce que ça règle le
problème de l'efficacité de la
légitimité des réponses apportées aux
crises au niveau européen je ne crois
pas du tout donc je serai pas en total
accord avec la thèse de quelqu'un qui
faut lire comme Luke van medelard à cet
égard il y a d'autres lectures qui me
semblent également intéressantes je
pense d'ailleurs à des travaux qui ont
été rendus accessibles en français par
le grand continent ceux de Jonathan
white notamment qui qui consacre des
développements importants à cette
question de de la politique de l'urgence
le problème en termes d'efficacité de ce
caractère collectif ou fragmenté
finalement
de ce pouvoir exécutif que quelqu'un
donnerait le Conseil européen
c'est que finalement encore une fois ça
produit cette cette relative lenteur
même dans la gestion des crises récentes
même dans la gestion la crise sanitaire
les premiers mois finalement sont des
mois on attendait une décision ce à quoi
on a assisté c'est un étalage de
division nationale entre les États on
avait tiré malgré tous les leçons de la
crise de la zone euro 10 ans plus tôt et
on a réussi à surmonter cette difficulté
liée à ce caractère fragmenté et
collectif du du Conseil européen
je crois que sur cette question
d'ailleurs du pouvoir exécutif même sous
une forme collective j'y pense
évidemment en écho à ce que disait
Myriam et ce qui a été dit d'ailleurs à
plusieurs reprises dans les discourss
luminaires c'est la difficulté au niveau
européen d'identifier de localiser où se
situe en réalité le véritable foyer
d'autorité vous avez utilisé ce mot
monsieur le Président dans votre
discours
et là je crois que c'est un véritable
question qui montre que le système de
gouvernance rationnel de l'Union
européenne ne répond peut-être pas
les plus classiques d'un système de si
ce n'est de séparation stricte des
pouvoirs comme vous pourrez le trouver
aux États-Unis au moins d'équilibre des
pouvoirs
on a davantage à faire un système de
d'équilibre des intérêts en réalité qui
caractérise cette gouvernance là
deuxième deuxième difficulté qui ne
semble découler
de ce de cette gestion de crise
finalement où le Conseil européen d'un
point de vue politique en tout cas et
central je mets à part la Banque
centrale européenne évidemment dans dans
cette dans ce dans cette analyse même
très très rapide la question de la
légitimité finalement la question du
Kratos dans un premier cas dans le
premier temps et puis la question du
demos dans dans le second ce qui me
semble aussi frappant c'est que dans le
système actuel on a davantage à faire un
système qu'on pourrait appeler
diplocratique et non pas démocratique au
sens le plus fondamental du terme parce
que là encore
cette fragmentation des diplomaties
nationales au sein du Conseil européen
produit non seulement un certain nombre
de problèmes en termes d'efficacité mais
aussi en termes de légitimité je crois
que cette fragmentation elle conduit à
une dilution de la responsabilité des
acteurs politiques finalement quand on
dit le Conseil européen a pris tel
décision de qui on parle en fait
fondamentalement est-ce qu'on est
capable d'imputer la responsabilité de
la décision
à tel ou telle chef d'État du
gouvernement étant entendu évidemment
que juridiquement et formellement chacun
d'entre eux ou chacune d'entre eux
d'entre elles ont une égalité de droit
mais que dans la réalité l'influence
politique diplomatique de tel ou telle
chef d'État de gouvernement peut être
différent en fonction des États membres
dont on parle donc dilution de la
responsabilité et puis une question qui
me semble aussi fondamentale même si je
m'aventure sur un terrain qui est
peut-être pas le mien un terrain de
philosophie politique donc je parle sous
le contrôle de Myriam revaudalon à cet
égard il me semble que ce degré
fragmentation aussi
conduit à poser une question qui est
fondamentale quand on évoque la question
de la représentation politique c'est la
question du mandat politique et du
mandat démocratique or il me semble que
la question fondamentale que pose la
centralité la primauté du Conseil
européen en cette gestion de crise c'est
comment définir ce mandat politique et
démocratique à cette échelle européenne
là est-ce que pour le dire dans des
termes peut-être plus simple plus
basique l'addition de 27 légitimités
politiques nationales de 27 mandats
politiques nationaux produisent une
légitimité politique européenne et un
mandat politique européen
personnellement je pense que la réponse
est NON et donc on doit effectivement
réfléchir aux modalités
institutionnelles capables de produire
ce mandat politique et cette légitimité
démocratique
si j'ai encore un petit peu le temps je
peux en deux minutes ou trois trois
minutes alors sous forme de conclusion
deuxième peut-être série de remarques
très brève sur la France parce que je
pense que la question qui nous était
posée se pose à la fois à l'échelle
européenne mais évidemment à l'échelle
nationale peut-être deux deux choses
même de manière schématique pour pour la
discussion
après les interventions il me semble que
d'abord selon ton a besoin dans notre
pays en matière de politique européenne
c'est d'un exécutif qui soit plus
responsable effectivement devant le
Parlement alors je suis je suis pas
complètement naïf et je sais très bien
que
les prérogatives constitutionnels du
président en matière d'action extérieure
et notamment en matière d'action
européenne font que le président n'est
pas comptable en tout cas de manière
claire de son action devant les
enceintes parlementaires ce qui pose
évidemment un problème mais qu'on
pourrait régler que par une modification
de la Constitution mais en tout cas je
voulais au moins soulever ce paradoxe
que le Président de la République est
affranchi également de tout compte à
rendre devant le Parlement français
devant lequel finalement il n'a pas le
droit de se rendre alors même que le
Président de la République peut aller
faire un discours au Parlement européen
et donc s'exprimer devant des euros
députés français au sein de l'assemblée
de Strasbourg peut-être évidemment sauf
à modifier la Constitution une
alternative pourrait être peut-être
envisageable deux pistes à cet égard
même de manière très brève la première
peut-être permettre au Premier ministre
de participer au Conseil européen c'est
tout à fait possible juridiquement ça se
fait en période de cohabitation mais on
pourrait élargir évidemment dans des
périodes or cohabitation ce dispositif
je pense que ça présente beaucoup
d'avantages permettent de rendre compte
de l'action européenne en fait au
parlementaire d'abord
plus grande cohérence aussi
institutionnelle dans la mesure
évidemment le Premier ministre a
autorité sur le secrétaire général des
affaires européennes
et dans la mesure où Gouvernement
détermine et conduit la politique de la
nation il semblerait normal évidemment
que dans une enceinte où des décisions
importantes pour la politique européenne
de notre pays pour nous concitoyens sont
prises que le premier ministre puisse
participer à ces réunions et à ses
négociations la deuxième chose pour
terminer peut-être sur sur ce volet il
pourrait être aussi intéressant
d'imaginer l'organisation d'un discours
annuel du président de la République
devant le Congrès ce qui permettrait de
fournir de provoquer finalement une
occasion de discussion entre le
Président de la République et les
parlementaires français sur les sujets
et les enjeux européens et puis ça
pourrait constituer évidemment aussi un
moment important d'information politique
pour les citoyens il faudrait réfléchir
d'ailleurs peut-être dans cette
perspective à articuler le plus finement
possible ce discours
potentiel du président devant le Congrès
avec le discours sur l'état de l'Union
de la présidente de la Commission
européenne
voilà j'aurais bien d'autres choses à
dire mais le temps est compté merci
beaucoup de votre attention
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup cher cher
Thierry Chopin pour cette mise en
perspective effectivement et ses
propositions très intéressantes sans
plus tarder je vais passer la parole à
Klaus vélo pour là encore une mise en
perspective et je dirais qui nous
intéresse d'autant plus que nous sommes
pratiquement à un an de notre séance
démocratique importante les élections
européennes de 2024 donc là vous avez le
pour un propos sur le Parlement européen
donc vous avez été secrétaire général on
l'a rappelé face aux crises bilan et
perspectives un an avant les élections
européennes pour une dizaine de minutes
avant de poursuivre l'échange avec la
salle merci
oui merci beaucoup et aussi merci
beaucoup pour cette invitation
peut-être avant que je commence avec mon
discours une très remarque parce que on
a discuté beaucoup sur le Conseil
européen mais je me souviens très bien
que c'était une initiative français dans
le temps c'était très lié au nom de
Giscard d'Estaing et je me souviens
encore qu'on ne parlementaire sont
revenus de la dernière réunion de la
convention ils étaient très frustrés
parce que presque tous les membres de la
Convention se sont exprimés contre
l'Institut scénarisation du Conseil
européen et il paraît je n'étais pas là
que Monsieur Giscard d'Estaing aurait
répondu mais moi je peux voir des
majorités futures
et donc c'est resté dans le texte donc
il me paraît aussi dans cette balade qui
est des questions européennes et des
questions français de des questions et
peut-être problème dans le lance du
session française se marie un peu dans
cette dans cette base ici
mais pour ma contribution
donc d'abord
qu'est-ce que c'est une crise et
peut-être là il s'exprime aussi un peu
le temps vraiment
à pour moi une crise c'est quand le
status quo ne peut plus être maintenu
une crise c'est quand le changement
devient finalement une obligation
[Applaudissements]
une crise c'est qu'on est nouveau reçoit
finalement ça change
on dit que la crise et l'heure de
l'exécutif
peut-être
la crise c'est plutôt le moment de ceux
qui ont anticipé
qui ont une idée du futur
qui sont prêts à agir et vite
c'est leurs idées
qui vont déterminer le chemin à prendre
quand finalement le rapport n'est plus
possible
les exécutifs et leurs appareils
aiment les parlements comme chambre
d'appui
réactif
il est séduisant d'oublier que la
légitimité finalement vient du peuple et
le leur représentant démocratiquement
élu
les parlements doivent donc être avant
agile et indépendamment indépendant dans
le réflexion
c'est donc très important que le travail
journalier ne domine pas le tout
il faut donner systématiquement une
place
au futur dans la réflexion
et dans l'action du Parlement
comment le faire en pratique
les parlements le mot à dire dans les
cycles législatifs et politiques
celui-ci qui va déterminer l'agenda a
déjà décidé
ce 80% du résultat
le Parlement européen a développé des
outils pour y arriver à long terme
à mi-temps et à court terme
l'élection du président de la Commission
européenne par le Parlement européen
tout au commencement de la législature
est une négociation qui prend des
semaines
le Parlement européen est une
institution
composée de minorité
même si la candidate comme actuellement
était sûr de la plus grande famille
politique
cela signe dispose de plus de 25% de
sièges
le soutien des parlementaires des autres
groupes politiques lors de l'élection
dépend donc des concessions sur le
contenu à mettre en oeuvre
pendant les longues cinq ans de la
législature
les crises évidentes et prévisibles
comme le réchauffement climatique
peuvent donc y être adressées d'une
manière précise et concrète
cette occasion se répète lors des
confirmations des candidats comme ici en
individuel
avant le vote sur le colère en son
ensemble
et permet d'adresser des questions
sectorielles et plus en détail
depuis la présidente du Parlement par
l'ancien Premier ministre
polonaise chez Boussac
l'institution dispose de l'instrument
pour actualiser ses accords dans une
perspective à mi-temps
le grand débat parlementaire avec la
présidente de la Commission européenne
chaque automne qui s'appelle l'état de
l'Union
c'est ce que je veux dire c'est pas
seulement un discours mais avant que la
présidente tonne son discours elle va
bien sûr
consulter les différentes acteurs
politiques pour voir qu'est-ce qu'il
fait le soutien
et dans le vif
le Parlement européen a fait
démonstration pendant la crise du covid
qu'elle était capable de faire
fonctionner une démocratie continentale
et multinationale de 27 pays de plus que
440 millions de citoyens ont digital et
en distance
elle a pu jouer un rôle
clé dans la solidarité
en poussant pour le programme multimédia
nouvelle génération l'Union européenne
le Parlement européen était le premier à
pouvoir saluer le président
ukrainien Céline ski ont débats
sa présidente Roberta metzola la
première chef d'une institution
européenne à se rendre à Kiev
les députés en avant du conseil de la
Commission européenne en demandant la
perspective de l'accès de l'Ukraine à
l'Union européenne
le Parlement européen a joué un rôle
décisif
en assurant que les crises en Europe ne
sont pas devenus des crises de l'Union
européenne
est-ce qu'il y a donc plus rien à faire
la permacrise de dernières années nous
montre bien que l'ordre international
est en train de est en train de changer
fondamentalement
l'agressivité russe contre les civils en
Syrie
provoquant la déstabilisation de la
politique en Europe par le flux de
millions des réfugiés et maintenant saga
contre l'Ukraine ont mis fin
à 30 ans de coopération paisible
la confrontation entre la Chine et les
États-Unis
s'accélère
d'une manière dangereuse
et va restructurer les relations
politiques et économiques mondialement
on risque fort
tenterait pas seulement dans une
nouvelle guerre froide mais peut-être
même une guerre chaude
le paradigme du prix
déterminant depuis la chute de l'Union
soviétique et maintenant remplacé par un
nouveau paradigme de sécurité
et la compétition de ce système
politique
il est donc
urgent d'améliorer nos capacités
d'analyse
et des risques
les services de recherche du Parlement
européenne
a développé pendant les dernières 10 ans
des outils qui nous soutiennent dans
cette ambition
la revitalisation de l'idée du coût de
la non-Europe soutenu par des centaines
de pages d'analyses mais en avance les
opportunités inachevées des croissances
sont dettes
le travail sur le récitémique très
probable à se réaliser et les capacités
disponibles ou non à les maîtriser
en forme sur un programme amitherm pour
éviter les crises les plus graves et
soutenir la résilience
la coopération entre ensitusnale espace
commencez à l'initiative du Parlement
européenne par rapport à la menteur de
la commission du budget rapporteur était
le député James ls au plus haut niveau
administratif sur le train globaux a
établi une base solide qui a facilité la
création d'un vice-président de la
Commission européenne
responsable pour la prévision
les réunions de ministres du futur et
l'établissement du centre d'expertise
dans toutes les institutions en bref les
structures de prévision
les crises ne doivent pas nécessairement
être affrontés et ça c'est la méthode
travail du Conseil européen par la
méthode dos contre les murs regarde la
bise
dans une nouvelle fonction
j'ai proposé de mettre la soutenabilité
au cœur de tous nos politiques pas
seulement dans l'environnement
Omar centre on propose une programme
d'action de 175 mesures sur les 7 d et
c'est ça les questions où je pense que
l'équilibre n'est plus n'est plus là la
défense
la dette la démocratie la démocratie le
digital la décabbonisation
et la déclobalisation c'est ce que
Madame fanaline appelle di rescale
la crise
c'est aussi le résultat d'une montre
d'action merci
beaucoup à tous les trois c'est
intéressant était très riche je suis sûr
qu'il y a beaucoup de réactions et de
questions nous ouvrons par une vingtaine
de minutes les interventions les
échanges avec le public donc je vous
prie de vous signaler devant la main et
on prendra une série de questions
intervention afin de permettre tous les
trois de répondre donc peut-être
monsieur là-bas
il y a pas de micro pervers peut-être
pour commencer et par la suite
derrière
merci excusez-moi d'être arrivé en
retard
mais
d'avoir entendu que la fin
d'intervention
de Klause mais évidemment c'est à cloud
adresser ma question car
dans le mot crise il y a une dimension
que vous n'avez pas mentionné qui est la
question de l'urgence et c'est une
question qui
s'inscrit dans l'ensemble du dispositif
institutionnel de l'Union européenne
puisque contrairement à un état régalien
qui est là pour protéger les citoyens
face à la guerre l'Union n'est pas
construite là-dessus et donc son rythme
de production
et de réaction n'est pas construite sur
le court terme sur la crise et c'est
d'autant plus vrai pour le Parlement
européen qui lorsqu'il exerce un pouvoir
l'exerce en tant que collé législateur
et du coup avec un temps de maturation
de négociation des laboration de
construction qui est un temps que
l'exécutif par définition considère
comme étant un temps trop long donc et
mais j'ai bien entendu ce que vous avez
dit que le Parlement européen avait bien
réagi notamment sous votre impulsion
pour passer en numérique au moment de la
covid ou de proclamer
que l'Ukraine devait devenir un pays
membres de l'Union européenne mais c'est
pas de ça dont on parle ce dont on parle
c'est ce qui fait que
l'exécutif court-circuite cherche tes
méthodes et des outils pour
court-circuiter le Parlement européen
dans le travail de collégislation dès
lors qu'il considère qu'il y a une
urgence donc comment
éviter ça et qu'est-ce qu'on peut
proposer pour
empêcher l'exécutif de fonctionner de
cette manière là qui est une manière qui
au bout du compte creuse un déficit
démocratique dont on n'a pas besoin
merci beaucoup pervers monsieur si
peut-être vous pouvez aussi vous
présenter brièvement avant de poser
votre question
Bernard je pense que ça se présente pas
bonjour David canne fédérale Europe
merci pour les interventions vous avez
très bien indiqué que les grands défis
les grands sujets se traitent désormais
au plan européen d'après les citoyens de
l'Europe et c'est le cas en raison de
l'interdépendance très poussée entre nos
pays et en raison des des risques
représentent les puissances les
superpuissances et vous avez d'autre
part très bien montré le manque
d'efficacité le manque de prévisibilité
de capacité à prévoir et le manque de
légitimité du Conseil européen qui est
de fait le centre du pouvoir des
institutions européennes
alors la question est très simple dans
ce cadre là et compte tenu de ces
éléments ne faudrait-il pas tout
simplement créer un gouvernement
européen fédéral
compétent pour certaines
choses limitées qu'on ne peut plus faire
uniquement en France ou en Allemagne par
exemple le créer avec quelques pays
fondateurs et ce gouvernement fédéral
serait évidemment légitime il serait
plus efficace bien sûr et il aurait la
capacité de prévoir comme peut le faire
le gouvernement américain merci merci
une dernière question de cette série
j'ajoute juste que cette proposition a
été faite par le gouvernement allemand
et la France pourrait se fixer comme
objectif d'aller dans cette direction
bonjour Guilaine lit climat étudiante en
droit ma question s'adresse à Monsieur
Chopin justement vous avez parlé du fait
que le Conseil de l'Europe soit une
sorte d'exécutif européen qui agit
justement de manière à pallier les la
collégialité qu'il y a au Parlement
seulement est-ce que là avec tous les
toutes les super puissances la crise
entre la Chine les États-Unis et que
l'Europe se place un peu au milieu de
tout ça est-ce que justement le
conseiller de l'Europe va pas essayer de
le Parlement plutôt va s'effacer face au
Conseil de l'Europe en vue de répondre
plus rapidement justement à ces crises
différentes voilà merci
si vous voulez commencer première série
de réponses
avec
plaisir
en effet je crois la la question de
pervenche Perez mais aussi les
introductions qui étaient faits
à pose la question exactement là où il
faut poser la question parce que là je
crois la description est correcte le
Conseil européen réagit sur les
questions d'État
classiquement les questions régaliennes
comme vous avez dit
et pourquoi est-ce que le Conseil
européen de faire
parce qu'il est devant la nécessité
et pourquoi est-ce que le Conseil le
fait en improvisé parce que c'était pas
réglé correctement dans les traités
ça veut dire il y a
il y a une manière d'adresser aussi le
contrôle démocratique ça veut dire de
d'accepter que au monde où on vit il
faut traiter d'une manière efficace par
exemple la politique être étrangère
sécurité défense au niveau européenne si
on est confronté par la Russie et
peut-être confrontée par les Chinois et
quelquefois peut-être même confronté par
nos amis
américains donc si on a le courage de le
dire de l'accepter on peut le mettre
aussi d'une manière organisée dans les
institutions européennes et à l'autre
côté
il y a le palme il y a le Parlement
nationaux
et
j'ai participé à beaucoup de réunions
avec les présidents de Parlement
nationaux et les secrétaire général et
de mon point de vue le problème
principal c'est que la participation de
Parlement nationaux et très réglée d'une
manière très très différente pas tous
les pas le monde donc c'est même très
difficile entre le président du
Parlement de ce palais on commence très
régulièrement par les présidents du
Parlement qui disent moi je n'ai pas le
droit de m'exprimer sur des questions
politiques
mais on a des modèles qui fonctionnent
les modèles qui fonctionnent sont les
modèles scandinave la grande chambre au
Finland le contrôle au Danemark si on
veut vraiment faire plus fort la voix
des parlements nationaux il faut il faut
une sorte gold stand up
pour tous les Parlement nationaux dont
le contrôle d'abord de leur propre
gouvernement
qui doit se justifier devant le
Parlement pour les décisions et les
actions que le gouvernement prend au
niveau européen et à ce moment-là on
commence à contrôler aussi l'action et
des décisions prises au cancer européen
qui sont en dehors du cadre du traité
européenne donc le plus bon conseil que
je peux donner au Parlement nationaux ça
c'est
de faire du modèle scandina fainois
danois
la pratique utilisée par tout le porno
nationaux dans le contrôle de leur
exécutive et de demander leurs exécutifs
d'accepter d'accepter ça à sa moment
aussi une coopération entre le parlement
national devient possible parce que si
on n'a pas les mêmes si on n'a pas les
mêmes droits ça devient très très
difficile d'agir entre par le monde
nationaux d'une manière ensemble au
niveau européen
c'était pour vous là
merci beaucoup pour pour votre question
de manière générale je pense que avec le
retour en fait des enjeux de puissance
et des questions géopolitiques
il y a plusieurs choses en fait qui en
découlent d'abord en fait une prise de
conscience de la nécessité de renforcer
notre sécurité et une fois qu'on a dit
ça une deuxième chose c'est
qu'évidemment comme il s'agit de de
sujets régaliens qui sont tous situés au
cœur de la souveraineté de l'État très
clairement le rôle des États et des
chefs d'État du gouvernement notamment
sera central et donc cette institution
qu'elle conseille européen le sera le
sera aussi
néanmoins une fois qu'on a dit ça
peut-être deux choses en matière et pour
faire écho est-ce que Klaus vient de
dire à l'instant en matière de politique
européenne et politique internationale
les modèles en fait des relations
sur les gouvernements nationaux et les
parlements nationaux sont très
différents d'un pays membres à l'autre
et là il se trouve qu'on est dans un
pays ici en France où il y a une
singularité de ce point de vue là il y a
une relative fragilité je le dis dans
des termes diplomatiques du contrôle
parlementaire vis-à-vis des prérogatives
constitutionnelles en fait de l'exécutif
et notamment du président de la
République en matière d'action
extérieure c'est pas du tout le cas dans
d'autres pays membres effectivement le
modèle danois le modèle allemand aussi
sont des modèles intéressants en fait
assez à cet égard et donc il faut il
faut il faut distinguer en fait les cas
les cas de figures nationaux de ce point
de vue là par ailleurs l'autre chose en
fait qui me venait à l'esprit en vous
écoutant poser votre question c'est que
sur ces sujets de sécurité de défense il
y a un enjeu je trouve très fort de
convergence entre les États membres et
il y a un travail de convergence à
réaliser sur différents registres on le
voit évidemment d'abord sur enregistre
stratégique la question de savoir ce
qu'on doit faire en réalité quand on dit
il faut renforcer notre sécurité
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire est-ce que ça
veut dire la question se pose avec les
milliards d'euros qui sont mis sur la
table en fait aujourd'hui avec les forts
budgétaires en matière de défense est-ce
que ça signifie
renforcer des capacités nationales en
matière de défense est-ce que ça
signifie renforcer et développer des
capacités européennes communes à
l'échelle européenne dans ce domaine
est-ce que ça veut dire renforcer le
pays européen de l'OTAN est-ce que ça
veut dire faire uniquement confiance à
l'autre c'est-à-dire acheter du matériel
sur étagère etc etc donc on voit qu'il y
a un débat très fort sur ce registre
stratégique il y a aussi un débat qui
devrait avoir lieu sur la question sur
le registre politique c'est-à-dire si on
décide d'aller dans une direction qui
nous fait renforcer nos capacités en
matière de sécurité la question de
savoir
et celle en fait laquelle est de savoir
comment à quelles conditions on utilise
finalement c'est capacités là et là
encore entre les différents États
membres les les conditions politiques en
fait pour pour utiliser des moyens de
défense on pas les mêmes d'un pays
membres à l'autre et le rôle des
parlements et variable entre les
différents pays européens donc là aussi
il y a un effort de convergence à
réaliser et puis évidemment aussi effort
de convergence sur le plan opérationnel
sur le plan industriel et je pense que
tous ces éléments-là de débats de
discussion
doit faire l'objet de débat et de
discussion aussi au sein des enceintes
parlementaires et pas uniquement entre
acteurs des exécutifs nationaux et
européen donc je trouve que même sur ces
sujets alors que ces enjeux sont
régaliens malgré tout les parlements
importants à jouer y compris dans des
pays qui singularisent en fait par la
relative faiblesse de leur contrôle
parlementaire vis-à-vis de l'exécutif
merci Myriam bravo Dallas ne voulait
peut-être intervenir où on peut ouvrir
pour une autre série de questions comme
vous le
souhaitez peut-être une série de
questions encore une dizaine de minutes
alors Bertrand Séné donc je suis
économiste écologiste
et je suis passionné également par les
questions de démocratie
dans la façon dont chacun a présenté les
choses on voit qu'il y a différents
angles d'approche sur les questions
démocratiques et moi il y a un angle qui
me qui me frappe beaucoup et que
j'entends beaucoup qui est que en fait
l'Assemblée nationale le Sénat et le
Parlement européen ne sont pas du tout
représentatifs de la diversité de la
population en réalité c'est une minorité
privilégiée dont je fais partie
d'ailleurs qui y est présente et qui
croit savoir ce qu'il faut faire pour le
peuple sans avoir l'expérience concrète
d'un grand nombre de problèmes qui sont
rencontrés par la population comme par
exemple la violence de l'inflation
aujourd'hui
et on imagine que si c'était d'autres
personnes qui étaient dans l'assemblée
on ne prendrait pas les mêmes décisions
par rapport à l'inflation aujourd'hui
en fait face
pour pour prendre des décisions justes
pour le peuple on a besoin de vrais
débats avec une diversité d'opinions et
une diversité d'expérience de vie or
l'appartenance à des partis politiques
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui dégradent
fortement la qualité des débats car elle
réduit la liberté de penser elle réduit
la liberté de critiquer et la capacité à
changer d'opinion qui est tellement
vital pour rechercher la meilleure
solution possible dans l'intérêt général
face au défi écologique et sociaux il me
semble qu'il est en fait grand temps de
mettre en place une démocratie de
l'intelligence collective beaucoup plus
représentative ce qui implique d'écrire
une nouvelle page de la démocratie
probablement sans parti politique et de
donner plus de place au tirage au sort
et moins aux élections ce qui
permettrait aussi d'accroître la
légitimité et l'acceptabilité des
décisions alors voilà je voulais vous
proposer de de rentrer sur cette
question du tirage au sort et je serai
absolument ravi de participer à un débat
sur les vertus et les vis de l'élection
et du tirage au sort sachant que je vais
bientôt publier un article sur ce sujet
merci beaucoup il y avait une aussi une
question au fond la si vous pouvez vous
présenter brièvement oui on sort merci
donc medilate j'ai étudiant à Sciences
Po face à la montée des idéaux extrêmes
sur la scène politique mais aussi des
discours de haine en lien notamment avec
les crises telles que les crises
migratoires ou sanitaires
quel rôle on les Parlement comment
légifertile sans pour autant empiéter
sur nos libertés fondamentales merci
beaucoup c'est une dernière question
tout au fond là-bas
j'en ai peut-être une dernière sur le
fait qu'on soit au Sénat pour parler
d'Europe et du fait qu'on parle
démocratie quand on voit une dynamique
on a une intégration de plus en plus
forte des compétences au niveau de
l'Europe et en même temps une
distribution de plus en plus forte du de
l'action concrète des services publics
par justement cette revendication de
représenter les territoires et de savoir
ce qu'on y fait avec une descente
réalisation dont on peut encore vouloir
l'accélérer comment est-ce que on recrée
justement cette démocratie cette
expérience de la démocratie européenne
quand on a un partage des compétences
qui est encore en évolution voilà
merci beaucoup mais donc c'est peut-être
donc commencer de Cloud et on va finir
sur
je vais me concentrer cela sur la
première question est-ce que le
Parlement européen est représentatif je
crois on est extrêmement représentatif
dont le meilleur et dans le pire
c'est vraiment l'image du continent en
large
mais j'ai eu aussi si ce permis de le
dire l'oppression ici
que peut-être la malaise en France est
aussi liée au fait que les grandes
pourcentages de la population dont la
Cinquième République sont
systématiquement exclus de la
représentation au Parlement peut-être
pour des très bons résultats pour être
pour des très bons raisons mais ne se
sont pas représentés et donc on voit la
violence
au Parlement on les a tous eu beaucoup
plus tôt on a eu Madame Le Pen au
Parlement européen elle est excessée son
mandat beaucoup de monde
oui
toutes les minorités toutes les pensées
toutes les réflexions trouvent leur
place et peuvent participer à la change
et moi je trouve pour moi ça c'est une
précondition aussi pour l'acceptation
des résultats
je n'ai pas de comment dire de réponse à
précise à apporter à chacune des
questions mais il me semble que je
pourrais faire une remarque sur ce qui
les motive et ce sont sur leur point de
départ il me semble toutes les questions
les dernières qui ont été posées sont
l'expression précisément de l'espèce de
malaise
et de la prise de conscience d'un
décalage entre la représentation au sens
procédural du terme et ce que j'appelais
tout à l'heure au fond l'esprit la
démocratie ou le fait de se sentir
représenté la question de la
représentativité formelle elle est pas
nouvelle elle se pose comme on va dire
elle s'est posée pour les comment dire
pour le moment de la Révolution
américaine elle s'est posée au moment de
la compagnie de la formation de la
Constituante en France et on sait très
bien que ce qui a été
[Musique]
la conscience d'un décalage ou une
dissymétrie entre la démocratie telle
qu'elle est mise en forme elle est
nécessairement mise en forme de façon
imparfaite et un esprit de la démocratie
qui ne coïncide jamais totalement avec
elle
peut-être un mot sur un sujet très très
large que vous avez évoqué sur la montée
des extrémismes et notamment des
discours de haine
évidemment je vais je vais pas répondre
à la question comment est-ce qu'on fait
pour lutter contre ce discours de ce
discours de haine parce que ça nous
mènerait très très loin et qu'il y a
beaucoup de de politique qui peuvent
être concernés en fait par ça mais le
mot en fait elle n'a intéressé et on
réfléchissant
comme citoyen comme politiste à la
question de la démocratie de démocratie
libérale à sa mise en cause en fait par
par les populistes mais et les
extrémismes de plus en plus en fait je
suis convaincu que l'un des clivages en
fait politique les plus les plus
importants c'est un clivage en fait qui
est nature émotionnelle
et on le voit en tout cas dans ce pays
on le voit dans d'autres pays européens
aussi
on voit que l'ensemble des crises pour
faire le lien avec notre sujet de ce
soir depuis une quinzaine d'années nous
font entrer dans un dans ce que
pierre-rose en vallon pour lequel j'ai
aussi une pensée évidemment aujourd'hui
à appeler un retour en fait de l'âge des
incertitudes et ce retour de l'âge des
incertitudes il produit de la peur de
l'angoisse de l'anxiété
évidemment en fonction des réponses qui
sont apportées ou qui ne sont pas
apportées à ce type d'angoisse ça génère
en fait des émotions politiques
particulières qui produisent des effets
politiques
la peur ne produit pas les mêmes effets
politiques que la colère le ressentiment
le sentiment de fierté blessé le
sentiment d'être méprisé le sentiment de
ne pas être reconnu tout ça génère
évidemment
quelque chose qui est de l'ordre de la
colère voire de la haine en fait si on y
répond pas et de ce point de vue là je
pense que les parlements pour répondre à
la question ou un rôle important à jouer
parce que les parlements sont composés
de gens qui sont élus
euh qui sont en contact de la population
qui sont les mieux placés pour prendre
le pouls de nos concitoyens et ça
permettrait évidemment de réduire
l'écart que l'on voit abyssal entre
ce ils ont un certain nombre de
décisions en tout cas de discours qui
sont qui sont tenus qui sont pris et la
réalité effectivement du ressenti des
émotions voir des passions qui
nourrissent aujourd'hui des divisions et
des clivages de plus en plus structurant
et je pense pour finir sur sur ce sujet
sur cette argument que
c'est majeur en fait ce défi qui est
lancé la démocratie libérale parce que
le libéralisme de manière générale à la
fois comme doctrine intellectuelle et
aussi politique a toujours eu beaucoup
de mal à penser en fait les émotions
c'est quelque chose qui a cherché en
fait en permanence historiquement et
jusqu'à aujourd'hui à substituer les
intérêts en fait aux passions s si on
laisse ce champ là complètement vacant
on sait que la nature politique comme la
nature a horreur du vide on sait très
bien que ce vide discursif en fait il
sera occupé par les forces radicales et
extrémistes
je voudrais quand même ajouter une
petite nuance à ce que vous avez deux
petites nuances premièrement sur la
question je voulais certitude la
démocratie par définition par essence
c'est le régime de la certitude on le
savait très bien quand les démocraties
s'opposé au régime totalitaire qui
prônait la transparence de la société
elle-même et au fond le régime de la
certitude absolue donc le problème ce
n'est pas alors pour moi ce n'est pas le
retour de l'incertitude mais ce sont des
conditions aujourd'hui qui font que
l'incertitude ne peut pas être acceptée
ou elle comment dire elle ne peut pas
être assumée c'est-à-dire que
on a abandonné l'idée l'avenir dessiné à
l'avance pour se trouver confronté non
pas à l'acceptation de l'incertitude
mais elle l'angoisse devant la certitude
le problème c'est peut-être la manière
dont par exemple des institutions nous
permettraient d'appréhender la question
de l'incertitude c'est-à-dire
la question de du sens ou de
l'orientation d'une société ne demande
pas qu'on est un avenir qui est
préfiguré à l'avance si on a un avenir
préfiguré à l'avance c'est pas la peine
d'agir donc c'est il y a quelque chose
qui est
la possibilité de l'action elle est
commandée par l'incertitude et la
deuxième chose que je deuxième petite
nuance je pense que ce n'est pas la
démocratie libérale en tant que telle
qui
comment dire ne n'arrive pas à penser la
question des des émotions ou des
sentiments je pense que c'est une un
certain type de rationalité économique
qui prétend se substituer à une
rationalité politique est une
rationalité élargie je rappellerai ici
Montesquieu
quand on dit quand même qu'il est l'un
des pères donc
du libéralisme politique Montesquieu
distingue à propos des régimes la nature
d'un régime et son principe la nature
d'un régime c'est son fonctionnement
c'est la façon dont ça marche
l'organisation les procédures les
institutions et le principe d'un régime
c'est ce qui le fait d'être et
Montesquieu dit qu'est-ce qu'il le fait
d'être ce sont les sentiments bon au 18e
on disait les sentiments donc l'amour de
la liberté ou par exemple la crainte
dans une tyrannie le sens de l'honneur
dans une monarchie etc donc peut-être
que c'est un travers beaucoup plus je
dirais récent que d'avoir oublié que il
y a une sensibilité politique qu'il faut
intégrer à l'intérieur de la rationalité
et par exemple
l'Aristote la colère est un sentiment
politique
la peur beaucoup moins
voilà
oui c'est vrai mais là mais de façon un
petit peu la peur et les transformer
elle est élaborée de manière rationnelle
mais quand les Grecs disaient par
exemple
un homme qui est incapable de se mettre
en colère n'est pas un homme libre
il voulait dire aussi que la colère
était partie prenante d'un certain type
de rationalité politique que
j'appellerai une rationalité élargie
donc je crois qu'effectivement c'est un
problème fondamental que d'arriver à
réintégrer ce registre des sentiments du
sensible à l'intérieur de la réflexion
politique alors que nous sommes
maintenant dans un type de raisonnement
qui ne cesse de les opposer d'un côté la
rationalité calculante de l'autre les
émotions comme on va dire on pense à
Platon et mon peuple qui est la grosse
bête en proie
passion et assez dérives donc je pense
que ça c'est un enjeu fondamental aussi
que d'arriver à réarticuler les deux
[Musique]